ladies and gentlemen please welcome
someone i am such a huge fan of hannah
waddingham
[Applause]
[Applause]
i first of all i loved watching you win
your emmy oh my god
i was just glad that i didn't swear for
30 seconds um i i just it's funny having
been at a oh here hold on
thank you my lady thank you at award
shows uh the majority of my life
um i've been going since 1982. yeah
thank you
for showing
how
one might have the opportunity to feel
in such an extraordinary moment i think
you really set a bar thank you i really
not for a split second thought that it
was going to be me i mean literally my
butt cheeks had arrived on that chair
i'm not exaggerating 30 seconds before i
went oh look there's a there's a box of
food ah
oh look they've got the screens god i
forgot there's seven
hannah waddingham and i was like
honestly it's a miracle that i even got
up out of my chair
i was so shocked funny enough feel the
exact opposite i feel like you were a
no-brainer i would bet everything i have
on you women
seriously that coming from you
this is a bit of a surreal moment i have
absolutely loved you all my life
seriously meeting gertie you kidding me
that's when i started hitting those
award carpets dirty
dirty but i think that ted lasso and e.t
have something very much in common which
is that
something was built a story was told
people were cast in it a group of people
got together and crafted something that
swept everywhere
in its ways
and utter
alchemy
it really is it's like i'm getting
chills everywhere i really it's crazy
it's magic in a bottle it's lightening
and
there is i think an inherent goodness
yeah um now
i
didn't know this about you
but that your family was in the opera my
mama
my beloved mummy yes she was a principal
at covent garden before i was born
that's huge yeah the royal opera house
covent garden yeah both her parents were
opera singers as well
and
she then stopped for 11 years to bring
up my brother and i and then she went
back into the chorus at the english
national opera at the london coliseum
and was there
until i then kind of
took up the mantle and i was doing uh
just before the pandemic broke i was
doing uh the pirate queen there which is
babylon schoenberg who wrote les mis
and i was singing
queen elizabeth the first which is high
high operatic soprano and i got to do it
on my mama's stage with her in the
audience
i could hardly sing
and i did it i did it for her because
blessed she has parkinson's disease now
so i was like come on we're getting you
out the house and you'll see me on your
stage and she came backstage afterwards
and she just said you sound so much like
me and your grandmother
by the way
you started dancing actually as well the
age of three ballet tap and jazz
and
and then by the time i was quite good at
ballet and by the time i got to like 13
14 my my ballet teacher to my parents
was just like right
she's gonna be way too tall for any man
to lift her they're gonna be like
and fall over but i didn't want to be a
ballet dancer anyway but i think it's
the core of dance so then cut to with my
daughter i just kind of naturally shoved
her into it and she was just like mummy
ballet is too calm
[Music]
you